you're around these guys with a bunch of
jewelry all the time and stuff you know
so save me I wasn't jewelry - you know I
[Music]
feel like put on like a Cuban I feel
like putting on the cocoon with like a
pendant or just like maybe just throw on
some tennis or just like no pendants
just like throw some tennis is on this
is like my most recent I wear this like
every day by walking
it's two-tone white gold and rose gold
it's very heavy it's like I forget how
much it's like it's like 600 grams 800
was a on it yeah
is it a - cause this is like $100,000
just this buck oh this baguette buck was
like 30,000 and then there's this one
this is like a little like 50,000 is the
baguette Cuban rose gold I actually have
like a chain that goes with it I got
like a big murder game chain that's what
connects to this it's just like my
murder gang logo so it's like it's like
the murder like it's kind of like the
murder font were here with like a little
gang on the bottom and it's just like oh
like one big piece like what gets us up
James are very expensive I know like
honestly a lot of people probably don't
think they're that much but they are
like this like some 15 pointers right
here
he's like 15,000 to 10 pointers right
here
he's like 10,000 over 30 pointers to
30,000 this is my favorite yeah no I
love I love the tennis look you know
casual days and stuff where I'll put
them all on together I know kind of like
how much people spend on stuff you tell
by weight just like looking at diamonds
I got this in Atlanta from Wafi my joy
in Atlanta so I got this probably like a
year ago and I got the time like I
wanted to start like getting more
bracelets and stuff so that I'll just
like throw on a bracelet and I'm just
like I have nothing else
rose-gold but gets some other diamonds
10,000 I got this rose gold ring it's
like the guys I want to say never even
wore this let me measure where I like it
oh yeah it's cool I bought this like a
real like 10,000 and I got to take these
to row like wedding bands put them
together I stack them I think they're
like 6k each or something I wear these a
lot and then I got the murder beefs ring
like 10 dozen like the signature MB same
MB off right here
I wear this time I think you like all
the time this is the og Marty piece
right here this is one of the first
pieces that I ever made from a jeweler
in Toronto named Chris Rock see jewelry
shut up Chris someone on Instagram sent
me this logo and I was like ah that's
pretty dope I was gonna use it as my
local probably like a long time ago like
seven years ago so and then I just kind
of ran with it so then I went from that
to this when I started making beats some
my one boy told me that you're like you
got to put like a name to your work if
you want to start like getting out there
and stuff so I was gonna start putting
my beats on YouTube I was like I'm just
gonna call it murder beefs cuz I'm a
murder beats and I'm ready beasts and
that you know people always wanted me to
change my name
want to go take my government name my
last name whatever you know but I just
want to stick with it because I felt
like I was building my brand pretty
quickly you know she's the mirror chain
you know rose gold saw gold lots of
diamonds I just wear it on like a tennis
this is like 15,000 I think 20,000
yes so this chef I got this made like
fire like a couple years ago it's like
very heavy I had a show in Canada for
New Year's and I needed my jewelry to
finish it before that so he didn't even
get time to put diamonds on the top of
it
I needed it like right away deaf murder
you know I cook up all do all the work
and shoes so we have this this is like
20,000 and then there's this piece this
is OG keep God first piece this is a
logo off of my first mixtape but I
dropped alright a couple years ago is it
made by a Vianney
of 10,000 well then I have this this is
like I just bought this like off a
random jeweler that came to my house
like last year like a martini cut across
it's not it look cool this is like it's
like eight thousand this is like a very
special piece I mean I got I bought this
off on my birthday
these are my two boys they passed away
smoked dog and cozy and I see that like
Meek Mill and likes people got like
picture frames and stuff so so I just
throw them on some Dennis's you know see
my boys might looking over here and
stuff you know makes me feel good those
by like 25 thousands of them
then I got this oh gee yrm piece made by
a Vianney and this is actually yellow
gold but I like dipped it too rose gold
so I could like wear it with all my
stuff but just like wears off
I started everything yellow gold so I
had like yellow gold jewelry you know
like this like this is like yellow gold
you know I think offset had all rows
he's like man like you should switch
everything rose I just liked how it
looked
you're not gonna see someone like with a
fake chain that's like rose gold some
[ __ ] you know so I just switched
everything the rose gold and I just
stuck with it like I always like wanted
like a cool watch I didn't ever do like
when I was gonna get jewelry or none say
about I was like man think it'd be cool
to get like a roll that's something you
know like I got this watch right here 40
40 millimeter presidential Rolex rose
gold he's got the baguettes in the dial
and stuff I bought this actually one day
I was like out eating sushi I kind of
got drunk and then I was like you know I
knew there's like a jewelry store like
around the block so I like I'm gonna go
in there let me see what they got just
walked out with this fish is a sake
purchase right here well I love this
watch you know very classy you know you
can wear this out want to go on a hike
you know where this one you know
whatever it's a plain Jane you know I'm
saying you need one it was probably like
40,000 I got the AP with the baguettes
in the band rose gold row I had the
2-tone and I wanted to all rose and then
at the time not a lot of people had the
baguettes in the band so I was like I
want to be like one of the first with
that so this is dope isn't one of my
favorite watches this watch probably
like eighty thousand hundred thousand I
know this watch went up like twenty
thousand since I bought it I bought this
like a year and half ago I don't buy
them planning on selling them and like
making money off it you know I'm saying
like well I want to have these forever
you know that I want for 40 years I want
to have a bunch of watching be like oh
yeah like I remember this watch and this
was you know offering back memories
this watch I bought for my birthday
Richard Mille LeMans edition a lot of
people that Richard values
I think officer as other moms want to
these watches are dope those sports
watches and stuff this is like one of
like 130 watches or something
this watch is spent like honey take on
an 8,000 to 8,000 I like to find out
like how it's made you know like these
watches like someone that can made this
watch you know I'm saying this watch
Mike to make it might have took a couple
months to make you know saying like it's
crazy that just like the machinery like
looking in the watches and stuff you
know it's just amazing you know I love
designing like most jewelry think I
designed it you know yeah I'm actually
like working on like cooking up some new
pieces right now so definitely do like a
part too sometime soon